we're here kapow comic convention in
case anyone didn't know what have you
come as today I'm Captain America from
The Avengers film I'm tank girl from
Tank Girl Red Hood from Batman and why
have you picked these particular
costumes the movie was fantastic cap was
a great character and I just tried to
pick the guy that I look the most like
from her film so yeah I shaved my head a
couple of months ago and everyone was
telling me how to do Tank Girl so I did
tango I have I either well I haven't
done too many DC costumes so this is one
I like a character I like so I decided
to do this one now how much work goes
into these kind of costumes cuz it all
sorts of bits and pieces going on out
there
it varies character to character mine I
started back in October so it was a long
and a very expensive slog and you know
there are other guys in our group who
are just as dedicated and you know just
as fantastic and we do that much with
some little and then there are customers
like me who I consider this more of a
closet cosplay because I own most of the
pieces already I have my costumes more
assembled than made but I do do the
costumes that take months and months to
make as well
this one was actually a pretty easy one
to put together most of it is just items
already had the helmet was a little bit
trickier but I built it in about two
days
so all looking great now I know as well
as being here obviously to have loads of
fun and all the kind of stuff that's
going on at Kapow which it's been great
hasn't it you also here for something
else on use it took me a little bit
about that yeah we're we're a group
called hair as long as UK there's a
whole bunch of us around the con today
raising money for the make-a-wish
Foundation it's a great cause we've been
doing it for years and and we just get
bigger and bigger every year and get
joined by more and more wacky characters
- yeah so where can people find more
about that charity and what you've been
doing and stuff if they wants to go
online maybe or something like that they
can either find us on Facebook where
heroes Alliance UK or our website is WWI
UK calm brilliant guys great to see you
you're looking great cake you've had a
fantastic time and good look for the
final contest
you